-White House press secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders
has been holding
a lot of press briefings lately,
but I don't think
all the questions
we need answered
have been asked.
So we decided to hold another
one right here, right now.
That's right,
Sarah Huckabee Sanders
and the "Late Night" press corps
are here in our studio
and ready to go.
So without further ado,
it's time for the "Late Night
White House Press Briefing."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Yes, Ms. Sanders, Ms. Sanders!
Ms. Sanders!
Yes, yes, thank you.
Seth Meyers,
"Late Night with Seth Meyers."
Secretary Sanders,
what are the most terrifying
nine words
in the English language?
-The President will still
be here in five years.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Next question.
What does Trump ask for
when he goes into Supercuts?
-Upside-down and inside-out.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Secretary Sanders, did you have
a nice Thanksgiving?
-I want to share a few things
that I'm thankful for.
And I think it would be nice
for you guys to do so, as well.
-Okay. I'm thankful
we can use clever editing
to make this nightmare of an
administration sound silly.
-You're not fixing the problem.
You're only making things worse.
[ Laughter ]
-That's fair.
What did Eric Trump say
when he showed up
for Thanksgiving dinner?
-"Happy Halloween."
[ Laughter ]
-Ah.
Yeah.
So close.
When was the last time
someone tried to drump --
tried to jump
the White House fence,
and who was it?
-This afternoon,
the First Lady and Barron Trump.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-If Melania could trade places
with any person,
who would it be?
-All of us in this room
and across this country.
-But given her choice, what
would be Melania's dream job?
-A single mother.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-If I can switch the focus
to the Democratic party
for a second,
how did a young Bernie Sanders
first arrive
in Washington, D.C.?
-Via horse-drawn wagon.
[ Laughter ]
-How often does the President
lie on Twitter?
-For the third or fourth time,
just today,
as well as 10 or 15 times
on both Thursday and Friday
of last week.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-How would you describe Ivanka?
-Very basic.
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience groans ]
-Oooh.
What does Paul Ryan think about
while he's having sex?
-President Reagan's
1981 tax cuts.
[ Laughter ]
-Who's worse --
Bill Cosby or Bill O'Reilly?
-Both Bills achieved
the President's priorities.
[ Laughter ]
-Who do you call
when Steve Bannon gets loose
and is running around
the White House?
-The Fish and Wildlife Service.
[ Laughter ]
-How does the President's
urologist describe Donald Trump?
-A small business owner.
-Well, it looks like
we're out of time,
so on behalf of the rest of the
press corps, have a great night.